e
as
[Música]
qué momento para estar vivo
blige es una serie llena de personajes
muy interesantes y complejos cosa que
podemos notar solamente en su
protagonista pues sí chicos un personaje
que no para de evolucionar a lo largo de
la serie pasando de ser un estudiante
cualquiera a un shinigami rompe madres
este cambio no sólo lo podemos ver en su
personalidad y en su forma de actuar
sino también con la infinidad de
transformaciones y formas distintas que
ichigo ha obtenido a lo largo de los
años verán yo crecí en la época de
dragon ball y es por eso que aprecio
cuando el personaje principal de una
serie se cabrea y obtiene una nueva
transformación mega poderosa porque si
dragon ball os enseño algo es que entre
más transformaciones mejor aquí no
venimos a ver conversaciones de la
trágica historia de nadie aquí vinimos a
ver puntazos y transformaciones locas y
si alguien le aprendió a goku ese fue y
sigo porque creo que es uno de los
personajes con más transformaciones que
existen y para celebrar que por fin la
saga final de plays va a ser animada
pues qué mejor que darle un vistazo a la
larga evolución de nuestro protagonista
debo avisarte que este vídeo está lleno
de spoilers de todo así que si no has
leído el manga y preferís guardarte
todas las sorpresas para cuando el anime
se estrene te recomiendo que no veas el
vídeo pero por otra parte si ya has
leído el manga conoces muy bien la serie
o simplemente quieres enterarte de toda
la jugosa historia que te voy a
presentar pues ponte cómodo y acompáñame
a ver todas las versiones de ichigo
kurosaki
[Música]
cuando el chico conoce a rusia para
salvar a su familia que está siendo
atacada por un polo él decide aceptar el
trato de roque y parar la espada con el
pecho y así logra convertirse en un
shinigami esta es la forma creemos en el
comienzo de bleach y es la de un
shinigami común y corriente un poco más
fuerte de lo común porque es el
protagonista y con una espada de 3 km
pero es la transformación base del chico
luego de que vi a cuya le rompía todo a
su madre y que seguir a cuenta que con
su poder actual no podría proteger a
nadie y chicos decidió pedir la ayuda de
urahara para que lo entrenará antes de
ir a la sociedad de almas a salvar a
rukia durante este duro entrenamiento y
chico lograría ser capaz de escuchar una
parte del nombre de su espada y aprender
a controlar mejor su poder con lo que
ahora podría usar sus hijas en problemas
esta forma además de aumentar el poder
de ichigo le permitía usar el ketchup
atenció a voluntad y poder comunicarse
con el alma de su espada
una vez aprendió a usar su chica y chico
pensó que nadie podría detenerlo pero
adivina que lo detuvieron y aún así con
todo el poder que suscita él le otorgaba
le dieron una paliza por lo que una vez
más tuvo que recurrir al entrenamiento
pero esta vez sería lloro bichi quien lo
ayudaría a entrenar y es en este momento
en el cual el chico aprende que para
liberar el poder de cada espada en el
universo de bleach debes aprender su
nombre cuando aprendes una parte del
nombre solo liberas una parte de su
poder pero cuando logras aprender su
nombre completo el arma tomaría su
verdadera forma y todo su poder sería
liberado y aunque un shinigami normal
usualmente entrena por meses e incluso
años para obtener su bankai durante su
duro entrenamiento y chico logra obtener
su bankai en tan sólo dos diez y medio y
se lanza de inmediato a partirse la cara
con byakuya su bankai tensa zangetsu
comprime todo su poder en la pequeña
hoja de su espada lo que le da un poder
inmenso pero el mayor atributo de su
bankai es la gran velocidad que le
otorga pues haciendo uso en la velocidad
de su bankai logró igualar el poder de
viajar
como todos sabemos y chico tiene uno
solo viviendo dentro de él que
constantemente trata de apoderarse de su
mente por lo que temiendo que esto
suceda y chico se le adelanta y decide
el tomar el control de éste hollow por
lo que decide buscar ayuda y qué mejor
para esto que cindy y el grupo de 'los
paisas' quienes ya controlan sus propios
geólogos así que todos juntos logran
enseñarle a ichigo a controlar el poder
de su colon por medio de una máscara que
el chico puede usar a voluntad y aunque
al principio y chico sólo puede usar
este poder por un par de segundos a
medida que avanza la serie él se
acostumbra a este nuevo poder y lo puede
usar porque eran despedidos de tiempo
sobra decir que obviamente esta máscara
potencia enormemente los poderes y
habilidades de ichigo pues cuando peleo
contra green joe éste casi lo mata pero
cuando uso la máscara logró derrotar a
green joe sin mucho esfuerzo y así fue
con muchos personajes más a ichigo le
partí a la cara hasta que se ponía la
máscara y se ponía amadísimo estaba roto
[Música]
durante su entrenamiento con zinc y los
va a estar no todo fue tan fácil pues
eventualmente ichigo perdería el control
y su solo winter no lograría apoderarse
de su cuerpo por un breve tiempo lo que
poco a poco fue transformando al chico
en un monstruo que no pensaba en nada
más que destruir todo a su alrededor
este monstruo cuenta con las mismas
habilidades de shinigami de ichigo pero
mejor es mucho más poderoso y mucho más
rápido sumando además que siendo un
hollow puede lanzar poderosos 0 este
monstruo fue tan peligroso que si los
demás consideraron matarlo para que no
se saliera aún más de control y
destruyera todo a su paso aunque justo
antes de eso y chico logra recuperar el
control de sí mismo y hace que el
monstruo vuelva a caer encerrado en su
interior
en su pelea contra ulquiorra aunque y
chivo estaba perdiendo él tenía fe en
que lograría encontrar una manera de
ganar pero a su [ __ ] madre tenía otra
transformación
como sabemos culturas de los pocos
espadas que tiene una segunda
resurrección oficiantes en sus dos
formas anteriores ya se estaba mareando
activo en esta porra sí que barrió el
piso con él pero debido a sus heridas
tan graves y a su deseo de proteger a
sus amigos ya no pudo mantener el
control y el hollow en su interior
nuevamente se apoderó de él pero esta
vez tomó control total de ichigo y no
tuvo una transformación parcial como
antes sino que se transformó
completamente en un vasto olor de que es
la clase de hollow más poderosa con lo
que el chico pierde cualquier sentido de
autocontrol y además de acabar
fácilmente con el que ahora trata de
hacer carnitas a sus propios amigos más
adelante en el manga se nos explicaría
el verdadero origen de este geólogo pues
durante un pequeño arco del pasado se
nos cuenta la historia de masaaki y zinc
los padres de ichigo y cómo se
conocieron durante este arco ahí se
liberó más dolor de artificial llamado
blanco que él mismo creó para poner a
prueba el poder y la calidad de su
creación por lo que lo envía a asesinar
tanto shinigami como pueda la cosa es
que este vasto olor determina hiriendo
gravemente a más aquí pero junto a y sin
ambos logran destruirlo
si una parte de este vasto olor de quedó
impregnada en el alma de más aquí por lo
que al nacer y sigo el alma del hollow
se fusionó con la de él es por eso que
tiene poderes hollow y es por eso que se
pudo transformar en un vasto olor de
control que ahora durante mucho tiempo
esta fue una de las formas más poderosas
de ichigo pues nadie podía hacerle
frente a este monstruo era poder puro
sin piedad ni control esta calavera
significa
durante cierto tiempo las
transformaciones y power up simples
tuvieron cierto sentido pero aquí fue
cuando las cosas ya empezaron a salirse
de control pues durante la batalla final
contra aysén literalmente ya no quedaba
nadie que pudiera enfrentarse a él ni
los shinigamis los vai ser ni rajar a
este consejo digo a medio mundo solo
tite kubo ya que imparable a ese y
cuando se acordó que tenían que
derrotarlo no se le ocurrió ninguna
manera lógica de rotar aysén más que
darle una transformación ultra amadísima
y chico lo que ahora conocemos como
tanga y chivo mientras está en seguida
mareándose a todos en el mundo real y
sin se dio cuenta de que chico era el
único que podría derrotar a ese porque
era el único que aún no había visto su
chica y por ende no funcionaría con él
por lo que para aumentar rápido su poder
y sin lleva a ichigo aldán game que es
como el camino que conecta al mundo de
los vivos con el de los muertos este
lugar es como la habitación del tiempo
de play por lo que mientras y chico
entreno en su mundo interior durante
tres meses en el mundo real sólo pasó
una hora al terminar su entrenamiento se
nos muestra que ichigo logró elevarse a
un nivel mucho más alto llega fusionarse
parcialmente con su espada fuera de los
cambios físicos como la cadena más larga
que se enrolla a lo largo de su brazo o
la propia sangre su que está adherida a
su mano ichigo tiene una fuerza y
velocidad normal con la que logra
abrumar a aysén bloquear todos los
ataques destruir montañas únicamente con
la onda de choque de su espada y comerse
uno de los ataques más fuertes de aysén
sin ninguna herida grave
aunque llegó la estaba ganando a aysén
con su forma tanga y probablemente pudo
haberlo derrotado por alguna razón pensó
que debía ir aún más lejos y derrotarlo
con un solo ataque aunque eso
significara sacrificarlo todo por lo que
se convirtió en el kit su gas tenso
final esta transformación es la etapa
final de zangetsu en la que sigo gana un
poder inmenso y casi imparable pero si
se usa el chico perdería sus poderes de
zinc y gam y cuando usa de esta forma el
cabello de ichigo se vuelve
completamente negro y es mucho más largo
su cuerpo está rodeado de vendajes y sus
ojos se tornan de un color rojizo es un
propulsor además de que su spa
desaparece y una energía oscura lo rodea
con la que puede crear una hoja y
realizar el único ataque que se conoce
de esta transformación muguet su un
ataque tan poderoso que acabó con nike
lastimosamente sólo apareció una vez en
toda la serie y nunca más se volvió ni
tan siquiera mencionar así que es poco
lo que se sabe de esta forma
dos años después de la batalla contra
aysén y chico descubre que hace parte de
una raza conocida como 'los fullbring
los fulvence son personas que tuvieron
un antepasado que fue atacado por un
geólogo por lo que un poco de la energía
del voló que haría en dicho antepasado y
eventualmente sería heredado a ellos
esta energía les permite manipular las
almas de los objetos y si se le tiene
mucho aprecio a algún objeto en
particular servirá como un medio para
invocar su poder en el caso de ichigo es
su insignia es nigam y que usa para
evocar sus poderes cada usuario tiene
diferentes habilidades pero en el caso
de ichigo bueno comenzó a entrenar para
controlar estas nuevas habilidades poco
a poco fueron evolucionando primero
usando su insignia podía materializar
una esvástica hecha energía que podría
usar como escudo como arma cuerpo a
cuerpo o lanzar como proyectil después
su poder evolucionó de nuevo y una capa
de energía lo envolvía por completo con
la cual también podía materializar una
espada con la que atacar y finalmente su
fullback evolucionó por completo y su
forma final era esta especie de armadura
blanca que además le daba una pequeña
espada el poder de este fullbring es
menor que el de música pero aún así le
otorga habilidades con una velocidad
sobrehumana caminar en el aire y
controlar el alma de los objetos en su
ultimo currín y chico es bastante fuerte
y casi casi le rompe la madre a sookie
sima pero después ya todos sabemos qué
fue lo que pasó
al final de esta saga rusia le devolvió
sus poderes de shinigami a ichigo pero
esta vez usando una espada que tenía la
energía de varios tenientes y capitanes
de la sociedad de almas por lo que
potenciaron sus habilidades pero además
de eso sus nuevos poderes de shinigami
se unieron con sus habilidades fullbring
así que chicos resultó con una nueva
forma de shinigami recontra mamá y sim a
su chica y en esta nueva forma cambia
varias cosas su espada por ejemplo sigue
igual de gigante pero ya no tiene la
misma forma de cuchillo de carnicero
sino que tiene una forma más elegante y
curva y a su traje se le agregan ciertos
adornos en el cuello y unas marcas
oscuras en sus manos con sus nuevos y
que sus habilidades mejoran tanto que
puede literalmente perforar el cielo con
sus ataques
en la misma pelea final contra kim jong
y chicos en perra y decidí acabar con
todo de una vez por lo que decide usar
su bankai y tan solo la liberación de su
banca y es tan poderosa que destruye la
dimensión entera en la que estaban
luchando visualmente su apariencia es
mucho más genial que antes teniendo su
ropa normal de shinigami pero agregando
los accesorios blancos que le otorgan
fullbring además sus palabras tiene
picos en la parte posterior y una parte
hueca porque se consuman quede activado
y chicos tan poderoso que sólo estaba
jugando con guinjoan antes de matarlo y
los capitanes tuvieron que ir a
vigilarlo porque era considerado una
amenaza para toda la sociedad de almas
[Música]
en el manga durante la saga de la guerra
-hace ball rompe a tensa zangetsu por lo
que el chico tiene que ir al palacio
real para que ni malla se la arregla
cuando por medio del mismo ni maya nos
enteramos que los poderes de ichigo aún
no están completos pues aún no conoce la
verdad sobre su pasado así que luego de
enterarse de la historia de sus padres y
de sus poderes quincy y chico gana una
comprensión absoluta de su poder por lo
que anima ya acepta forjarle
personalmente su nueva espada una vez ni
magia termine de forjar la y chivo saca
el agua dos espadas una pequeña que
simboliza sus poderes quincy y una más
grande que simboliza la mezcla de sus
poderes hollow y shinigami esta se nos
dice que es la verdadera forma de
zangetsu y al obtener la y chico accede
a todo su poder completo con esta chica
y chico se vuelve tan fuerte que puede
pelear con varios queens y al mismo
tiempo y derrotarlos casi a todos sin
muchos problemas sus habilidades no son
muy distintas a la fuerza y velocidad
que sus hija y anteriores le
proporcionaban sólo que claramente ahora
es mil veces más fuerte que antes la
única habilidad que pudimos ver en esta
forma fue él lo cual son dos gatos ultra
potentes lanzados en forma de cruz
[Música]
cuando el momento de partir se la
quedará con juha finalmente llegó ichigo
fue con todo y lo atacó con su recién
potenciado cicae pero obviamente
considerando que gioja es el villano más
roto de blake esto no funcionó así que
el chico realizó un plan en el cual
usaría los ataques y la energía del
padre de todos los queens y para
despertar sus poderes latentes y cuando
por fin lo hizo logró combinar sus
poderes solo shinigami y quincy en una
sola transformación en esta forma uno de
los cuernos del vasto olor de aparece en
su cabeza y una de sus espadas se vuelve
completamente blanca simbolizando que
ahora sus poderes quincy están activos
pero no sólo su apariencia física cambia
pues ichigokan a un abismal poder en
esta transformación sólo con liberar un
poco de su energía destruyó el castillo
en donde estaban luchando y cuando se
puso serio obligó ayuda a usar sus mamá
decimos poderes en este estado y chico
puede usar ceros y una técnica que creo
en la cual usando una de sus espadas
como un segundo cuerno crea un gran rey
cero y lo combina con un get suka tenso
creando y una de sus técnicas más
fuertes
luego de un par de minutos peleando con
juha y chico estaba recibiendo la paliza
de su vida y tuvo que recurrir a su
última opción para ganar activando así
su nuevo y mejorado banco pero un
milisegundo después de su hija se lo
rompió
y afortunadamente con ayuda a sookie
sima pudo recuperar su espada y usó su
banca y brevemente en la pelea final
lastimosamente fue visto por muy poco
tiempo y lo poco que se vio no fue
ninguna habilidad especial ni nada solo
un par de que at&t u-verse y sigo
hablando sin parar esa enorme espada aún
así este banco es considerado uno de los
más fuertes por dos razones la primera
es que pudo hacerle daño a un casi casi
omnipotente hija y la segunda es porque
el mismo quincy admitió que rompió el
banca y de ichigo porque aun con el alma
eric y sus lazos el poder de este banco
era tan grande que podría acabar con él
y por eso prefirió evitar la fatiga y
romperlo antes de que si tan siquiera
pudiera usarlo esta vez extrañamente la
apariencia de ichigo no cambia al
activar su bankai pero su espada se
vuelve enorme con una cuchilla blanca y
negra con una pequeña cadena adherida a
la parte posterior dado que sólo
apareció en los últimos capítulos
esteban kai es considerado uno de los
mas desaprovechados pero irónicamente
uno de los más poderosos
desde que el manga terminó una de las
preguntas más grandes que quedaron fue
qué pasó con la espada de chivo pues en
los últimos capítulos se ve a ichigo con
la sangre de su antigua pero entonces
qué pasó con las dos zangetsu y porque
su banca y se rompió y te como
recientemente a través de internet
respondió esta pregunta pero la
respuesta es bastante vaga y difícil de
comprender así que haré mi mejor
esfuerzo para poder explicarlo según
cubo para con esa para que todo funcione
de manera correcta se necesita de la
espada y la funda y dado que ichigo
nunca tuvo una funda para sangre y su
espada estaba incompleta pero cuando
anima ya forjó nuevamente a zangetsu la
corrigió pues ahora tendría dos espadas
una simbolizando la cuchilla y la otra
simbolizando la funda por lo que está la
espada doble de chico es la forma
correcta de zangetsu su verdadero chica
y ahora éste es su chica pero su banca y
funciona de otra manera en su banca y
una de las espadas la que representa la
cuchilla toma la forma de la zangetsu
original y la otra espada la que
representa la funda recubre la sangre de
su original potenciando y complementando
su poder por lo que al romper su bankai
sólo se rompió una parte de él pero todo
el poder aún seguía dentro de ichigo es
decir ese sigue siendo su verdadero
bankai pero entonces porque el chico en
el más reciente capítulo tenía a la
antigua zangetsu bueno según cubo y
chico ha ganado tanto control sobre su
poder que él puede decidir qué forma le
da a su espada en el último capítulo y
chico tenía a ésta zangetsu pero si él
quisiera podría usar su forma dual la
cosa ya es más de preferencia del chivo
pues él puede elegir qué versión de
sangre se usar como les dije la
explicación es algo confusa pero esa es
la verdad
este es el sica y verdadero de ichigo y
este es su verdadero bankai sólo que su
chica y puede cambiar de forma entre
estos dos y una parte de su banca y fue
roto pero ya se recuperó si quieren que
haga un vídeo explicando más a fondo
esto hágamelo saber pero de momento esa
es la forma actual y definitiva del
chico una en la que controla a la
perfección todo su poder
de acuerdo hasta aquí va loca no estas
17 transformaciones que te acabo de
enseñar son todas oficiales y provienen
de el manga y de la cabezota de tite
kubo pero aún así existen otro par de
formas que no se consideran del todo
canon ya sea porque aparecen en
películas que no fueron creadas por tite
kubo o por ser parte de algún videojuego
pero de igual manera te las voy a
enseñar porque no dejan de ser muy
interesantes y la mayoría con un diseño
genial
durante la cuarta película de play it
pudimos ver una nueva transformación
para el chico en la cual obtiene los
poderes de un guardián del infierno lo
que le da un poder inmenso capaz de
igualar o superar los de su forma más
color de cuando entra en este estado el
cuerpo de ichigo se cubre con una
armadura esquelética y todos sus ataques
son mucho más potentes y se tornan de un
color dorado además de que obtiene un
control parcial de las fuerzas del
infierno
lit great soul es un juego para
celulares en el cual puedes usar a casi
todos los personajes de play este juego
aparte de ser muy entretenido y tener un
par de años al parecer es muy querido
por tite kubo pues el mismo les ha dado
permiso para crear personajes originales
para promocionar el juego incluso siendo
el mismo tite kubo quien crea los
diseños de estos personajes porque
seamos honestos nadie más puede hacer
diseños tan geniales como él para
celebrar el segundo aniversario del
juego se creó esta versión de ichigo en
la que logra controlar su forma vasto el
orden y la fusiona con su poder de
singani resultando en un hechizo con la
piel totalmente pálida y el cabello
mucho más largo además de tener las
manos y pies con las garras de su forma
hollow
esta versión de ichigo es especial
porque crea una fusión perfecta y
completa de todos sus poderes o en sí
shinigami fullbring y hollow todo en una
sola forma visualmente su cabello se
vuelve ligeramente más largo y obtiene
un traje negro con franjas azules que
recubren todo su cuerpo y es compartes
de este mismo traje que puede formar un
arco con el cual dispara flechas de
energía comprimida que destruyen todo a
su alrededor según el juego esta es una
de las versiones más poderosas y
peligrosas del chico pues cada ataque
resuena con una combinación en armonía
de todas sus habilidades
el quinto aniversario del juego fue un
evento muy esperado y para celebrarlo
por todo lo alto
decidieron nuevamente con la bendición
de tite kubo crear una versión especial
de vida cuya y otra de ichigo esta
versión de ichigo no usa sus poderes
queens y su lugar combina sus poderes
hollow shinigami y fullbring en una sola
forma aunque evidentemente sobresalen
más sus poderes fútbol siendo las
habilidades más presentes en esta forma
a esta versión los fans leyeron el
nombre de fuguet psuv debido a que su
apariencia es como la de mujer superó
con su armadura blanca de full frame
cubriéndole casi todo el cuerpo este es
uno de los mejores diseños de archivo
que yo no he visto visualmente su
cabello se vuelve negro y más largo su
ropa de shinigami ahora está cubierta
con la armadura blanca que le
proporciona su fullbring de su espalda
brotan dos extrañas figuras de color
rojo formadas de su energía y su espada
cambia de forma teniendo una empuñadura
cubierta alrededor de sus manos lo que
en general no sólo lo hace una de las
versiones con mejor diseño sino también
una de las más interesantes
y estas son todas las formas de ichigo
que hay hasta el momento en total 19
versiones distintas en las que podemos
ver a ichigo rompiendo mares
espirituales
ahora lo bueno es que en octubre de este
año después de ocho años el anime por
fin volverá y el manga parece que va a
continuar con este nuevo arco del
infierno que tite kubo inició el año
pasado así que aún hay posibilidades de
que el chico vaya a tener aún más
transformaciones locas lo que
afortunadamente significa que nos queda
plate para rato y dime cuál de todas
estas es tu versión favorita y cuál
crees que es la más poderosa si quieres
más vídeos de play o de alguna otra
serie díganmelo en los comentarios y si
surge alguna idea interesante me pondré
a trabajar en ello hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]